[Music]
one of the biggest dangers listen to me
one of the biggest dangers that can
stunt your entrepreneurial spirit in
life is when you grow up and you start
hitting plateaus misfortunes failures
breakups anything that breaks your heart
at some point we go from becoming these
emotional creatures but we're a
childlike and we play and everything is
possible and we dream and all fantasize
and we become too illogical when that
happens the fire imagine the fire is on
it where you can light up the world with
your ideas it gets turned off and then
everything's wiped out when it comes
down to creation mode see the reason why
today in this video I want to talk about
this because look if you think about the
greatest entrepreneurs and you study
them you will see they may be 45 years
old and age wise we could call it an
older person or whatever you want to
call them but their spirit is childlike
now childish not silly not immature
child like and today I'm gonna talk
about why 11 reasons why the best
entrepreneurs are childlike and I'm
doing this episode today from a very
significant room very special we rented
out in Tara Wicca castle and if you've
never been to though he could Castle I
every year I take a group of executives
this year was 60 of them and we go to
different places we've gone to Italy
we've gone to Dubai we've gone to
different places around the world where
we do this with and we will rent out
nice places this year we decided ran out
or he could casualty confounders place
it's based in Long Island right outside
of New York it's a hundred and nine
thousand square feet it was built
between 1914 to 1919 took five years to
build this place up
it's got 126 bedrooms it is now a hotel
and you can buy it right now if you want
to make an offer for 150 million I was
with the owner last night just a
beautiful property and one of the rooms
the one we're in right now just call the
chaplain book because many people have
partied here Rockefeller is the Clintons
Trump's president celebrities Hollywood
Jordan athletes Chaplin you know the
Great Gatsby movie was inspired author
of you know Fitzgerald when he wrote
Great Gatsby he looked at a building it
was this building though we could Castle
and he wrote the book based on this
property that he saw this
most chaplains room you see Chaplin all
over the place if you read the book art
of seduction of rock by Robert Greene
there's a whole section of how Chaplin
by being this childlike figure you know
seduced so many women and audiences
where people would watch him and they
were fascinated by his spirit it was so
attractive people loved him and then
eventually this guy's career takes off
because his childlike his creative all
this other stuff by doing all these
silent movies what are they calling the
movies that had no noise is it silent
films they were doing and all of a
sudden movies go from silent films - now
there's salad there is there's a sound
in it and then he didn't want to adjust
because he liked doing the silent movies
more he didn't wanna just that this guy
went from being so creative - all of a
sudden being so logical and his career
didn't end well for this guy how did
that even happen see it doesn't matter
how old you are right now you may say I
am the most creative person I'll ever be
anyone can turn off the fire at any
point if you don't pay attention to this
part so let's get right into it 11
qualities 11 reasons why the best
entrepreneurs are childlike number one
they're constantly speaking the dream
language see my boys I have two boys and
they're always talking to dream language
the other day always it's always some
kind of a dream we're talking about here
it doesn't matter what it is dad look at
the Stars dad you know hey look over
there hey pop did you see Santa Claus
it's Santa Claus did you see it's always
this this this this fantasy world
they're living in is this a man it's
this dream world they're living in and
and us adults we become too good to
believe in Santa Claus we become too
good to believe in dreams we come too
good to believe in fairy tales we become
too good to believe in all these things
that are possible and they don't and by
the way neither do great entrepreneurs
great entrepreneurs still fantasize
great entrepreneurs still dream great
entrepreneurs still think things are
possible
do you know great entrepreneurs most
people if you hang out with great
entrepreneurs that are constant creating
things if you hang around them for too
long you know what you would say sky's a
little bit off this guy's completely did
you see what he was saying
he's crazy was he smoking something was
he drunk was what he was talking about
early was absolutely insane I think he's
got psychological problems
the world would call some of the best
entrepreneurs in the world that view the
world in a completely different way
psychologically off because the rest of
the world at some point lost the flame
because they became too logical and
they're still in the imaginative mode
and they can't fully understand why they
think the way they do because they're
childlike
just like kids always thinking my dad
what if we could do this imagine if we
can do this great entrepreneurs do that
as well number two they come to you with
different approaches until you say yes
they come to you with different
approaches until you say yes for
instance hey Dad can I have some
chocolate
no that you can't have some chocolate
right now they go in becomea but daddy I
need some chocolate who says you need
you want no no I need some chocolate
daddy why do you need some chocolate
because I need it
why do you need it because I need it
daddy and okay that doesn't work so then
they go come back and they strategize
with the two brothers then they come
back daddy daddy I love you so much
daddy I love you so much can I give you
a kiss on the cheek and you forgot about
it you completely forgot I haven't
forgotten about what they want they have
one outcome they want that chocolate and
they come in and kiss you and they how
can they tell you how much they love you
and then they say daddy can I have some
chocolate and you say I'll get you some
chocolate come on Kay let's go get some
chocolate it's the same exact thing it's
like going back in negotiating with
somebody and you can't go back with a
different way of negotiating until they
say yes see entrepreneurs are childlike
just like kids come up to us
renegotiating and we don't even know
about it and they just simply change
their approach and they change their
approach and they change the approach
onto you and I like suckers we say what
yes I'll do business with your son let's
get you two chocolate number three
number three years there they persuade
emotionally instead of logically so let
me explain what I mean by that where
they persuade emotionally not logically
adults think children feel let me say it
again adults think children feel they
feel things right like have you noticed
when kids go in a room and they look at
an adult and they kind of check in the
mouth and they're feeling how they are
and they're kind of like not getting too
close and all this other stuff and
they're kind of because they're feeling
they're not just thinking they're
feeling so everything is emotionally
and everything becomes logical no this
is to this this is to dad this is to
that and we become these logical robots
you may as well you know people are
worried about robots taking over the
world let's face it people are becoming
robots forget about robots people are
robots nowadays you don't need to worry
about robots
most people have become robots because
they're living so logically instead of
tying their emotion to something they
want to do and going after not saying I
cannot pull this off number four too
innocent to understand what's impossible
to Innis innocent to understand it's not
impossible you know we say hey we can do
this why not daddy we're going to go on
to move one day you know we're gonna go
do this one day daddy you know what I
want to do what you want to do I want to
be a police officer why so I can arrest
the bad t-rex you I'm sure you wonder
what I want to be a police officer daddy
my son will say crazy things I'm like
what the heck did this kid just say I
want to be police officer because I want
to arrest the t-rex because the t-rex
sometimes they fight and they get the
smaller dinosaur and I want to rest
about t-rex oh where did this idea come
from it's that movie with the dinosaurs
and I what's that cartoon with the
dinosaurs and do you know what I'm
talking now what does it call that for
time no no the new one there's a new
cartoon with dinosaurs in it it's a you
know the green dinosaur
anyway so there's what's the call the
good dinosaur that's what it's called
the good dinosaur right and then there's
good dinosaur there's bad t-rex so what
the heck is this kid talking about when
he's sitting there telling me about that
we're going to have these cops are going
to arrest these t-rexes and then we're
going to fly on the moon and we're going
to live on the moon and Thomas and
Friends they're going to get on the
train and we're going to go where are
you going with this like what you guys
talking about with this see that to you
and I may sound crazy but you know
what's crazy here's what's crazy do you
know what is the biggest selling movie
of all time do you know what is the
biggest selling movie of all time
Star Wars t know why because it taps
into a certain level of imagination with
you and I that we logically can't go to
that we need somebody to take us there
because we sit and we say
my gosh what a fool what if I could be
this guy in this hero you know how these
guys show up and Chewbacca's and all
that what if we could want this will be
crazy you know why we watch that movie
and it makes billions trillions as much
money as it makes you know why because
we want to go there we want to go there
now at some point when we were six years
old we were there but we left there we
kind of need to go back there and get
that fire lit up again number five
number five number five list is they're
extremely curious they're fully curious
hey daddy what is this daddy like this
kid will sit there you know that thing
by the door like what I call that thing
than anything else what do you call it
is that what you call it
doorstop it's a really a doorstop this
kid will sit there and he'll just play
with that thing being tired and
sometimes I'm thinking he's thinking
he's playing with something else maybe
used to because like a boy he's like
anyways let me get back so he plays with
this thing the entire time he's so proud
of it right he plays with this thing
like pop what are you doing then he took
it out why just keep taking you know the
entire time I don't know to take it out
just watching like it's taking just goes
like this he takes it out then he goes
brings another one takes it then he puts
a toy inside of it so now when we close
the door you know the whole thing that
makes it softer when the door closes
it's even softer than it was before and
you don't even hear that so it doesn't
go tack it's softer he just goes you
don't hear anything so how did that
happen this kid is sitting there messing
around with it until he figured out what
he wants it because simply he's curious
what is this daddy daddy what is this
daddy what do you do with this think
your daddy
non-stop these kids are so curious and
we lose that level of curiosity as we
age number six a reset meant talent you
know it's a reset mentality you know
Dylan man this kid Dylan is so charming
but here's how villainous Dylan the
other day climbs the couch he falls off
the couch he cries for 13 seconds then
all of a sudden he goes and he plays
Lego and he completely forgot about the
fall it's like reset reset this never
happened forgot about it just quickly
complete forgot about it you know what
we do as adults
she don't sell what happened man what
happened she broke my heart oh really
yesterday no it was like two years ago
bro man I'm still dealing with it are
you kidding me bro two years ago you
could reset breakup she don't exist move
on you know I'm saying like
set and move on and we don't do it our
reset is two years the reset is a half a
second they just move on their shortened
memory there's a benefit for it some of
the greatest basketball players
quarterbacks the best performance that
as athletes they have a short memory
it's a very solid strength of shooters
they should say Kobe's got the shortest
memory in the NBA one time this captain
is 21 shots in Iran you know how he shot
the 22 second one as if he's been making
ten in a row and then he made it he says
you gotta have a short memory and he's
right number seven number seven charm
their way into getting anything they
want they charmed their way into getting
anything they want they charm you know
how to charm you they'll come to you
they look at you with their eyes and
they'll do their whole thing with their
eyes one of these things and they'll
smile at you then they'll say stuff to
you and like even you know they know how
to do it from earlier my daughter right
now she seduces me she's six months old
she looks at me she goes like this and
she kind of looks away like she's not
interested at six months old they know
how to seduce at six months old at two
and a half years old three years old my
son seduces me all the time he doesn't
even know it the way he does he looks at
me he's about to get a Papa and he goes
like this and he goes like this and he
kind of looks at me like that I'm so
sorry and you're like I can't even
discipline this kid right here right
they charm they seduce their way into
getting whatever they want
number eight their mind never stops so
let me explore what happens when their
mind never stops you know we as we're
kids and we're growing up we're being
fed so many different experiences so
quickly so many different experiences
Kaka so when the mind is was let me
explain it this way imagine when you
were working out five days a week okay
versus working out once a week which one
allows you build muscles more often five
days a week not once a week our mind
stops working five days a week it now
just works once a week because to us
becomes what I'm going to work and
here's what I do and I clock in and this
is all I do today and this is all I do
tomorrow and our mind is no longer
getting new experiences it's the same
experience as that for 20 years 25 years
30 years 35 years nothing news being
feted so it's not working at five days
we kids their brain muscles and
imagination work seven days a week
24/7 it works ours doesn't anymore you
got to get this thing working again like
you did before
number nine they learn faster because
they make mistakes faster we don't make
mistakes fast in a matter of fact I'm
here to tell you we don't make enough
mistakes okay there's a saying that I
have when I work with my peers and
anybody I'm meant to on any of the
executives I need the staff I need the
salespeople
I don't mind you making new mistakes I
do mine old mistakes but I do my new
mistakes matter of fact make new
mistakes faster the biggest difference
between the bigger guys and the smaller
guys is they make mistakes much faster
than the rest do number 10 number 10
here's number 10 10 is a very simple and
a unique one to most people as big as we
become adults life becomes a job it
becomes a chore being married as a chore
having kids as a chore running a company
is a chore becoming an executive as a
chore to kid's life is purely a game
they're playing again 24/7 so what does
that mean do you know what happens if
life is a game let me tell you what
happens if life is a game if you treated
life as a game you'd be having a lot
more fun with life they're having fun
they're having fun yes of a pack come on
man I have a job after pay two bills all
this other stuff so what you have to do
that find a way to have fun with it you
figure out a way to have fun with it you
can do that we have we figure out ways
to have fun at our office all the time
we have to figure out ways a fun auto
company all the time believe me this
intact and we're having fun right one of
the things we were talking about one of
our guys we come to the Lika casters
just oh my gosh rumor has it this place
has ghosts these guys are more you put a
note underneath his what was it you put
underneath it he says you're not that a
newspaper was that a look it puts a
newspaper clipping under the door he
says you're not alone and this guy is a
guy that's completely freaked out about
what he called a ghost and Mario mr.
pranksters famous for you know pranking
people he puts this thing underneath it
and say you're not alone and we talk
about ghosts all morning today because
he's concerned about ghosts two guys are
very concerned about
what happened there we're here for a
gathering and this is a very serious
gathering but you always got to find
some time to have fun because it's a
game and by the way those who learn to
play this game the best and have fun at
it always when they just always win no
matter how much people make fun of
Michael on how bad he wanted to win
Michael was the guy when kevin garnett
was a rookie you know basketball player
coming in microswitches Kevin Garnett
shorts from a double extra-large to an
extra small shirt and sir Kevin Garnett
was 611 sporting bshorts can imagine how
tight these shorts are these are
baseball players that put you know they
fire up the cleats of their teammates
and a tighter shoelaces underneath
together so when they stand up and they
fall if you learn how to play this game
and have fun at it
you'll be very very good at it and
you'll actually enjoy it and you'll be
able to do it a lot longer than burning
out too soon and last but not least last
but not least childlike mindset
entrepreneurs of a childlike mindset
they are always in creation mode
typically your shoulder is given up
they're always in creation mode they are
always in creation mode they're
constantly creating Legos when we were
kids in Iran Legos were like the rich
man's kid the rich man's toys rich kids
toys if you play with Legos in Iran you
were rich that's how we viewed you who
has you know Legos no one's got Legos
right Lake oh you must be very wealthy
must have million or families my son
Tico will take these Legos and said that
I made a ship that I made a plane that I
made this dad look what I made I made a
boat that look at this over here dad
look what I made over here it's constant
creation mode the other day the other
day at our house one of the biggest
blinds falls okay biggest blinds falls
these guys Tico and Dylan I keep feeling
like something's going on over there
they're walking with this eight-foot
blind a three year old and a four year
old they're carrying the blind time like
where are these guys going with this
thing so I'm just trying to let them go
and do their same I go falling is you
seeing what they're doing so they're
walking they take this big blind in the
toy room from the top angle it's eight
feet and you know what they're doing
from the table they're putting these
cards that are going down
you fly up in the basket and they're
trying to see if they can make it in the
basket that's three feet off the top and
then you know what I do and I go and I'm
like this is actually pretty funny game
I started playing the game with them
because they're constantly in creation
mode and the more you stay in creation
mode the more you can keep yourself
there if you can that's what the great
entrepreneurs do they stay in creation
mode creation mode keeps creating more
things if you don't create you lose the
muscle of creating so there are a lot of
other things I talk I can talk about
about why the best entrepreneurs in the
world tend to be extremely childlike but
I got 11 them here for you to go through
so here's what I want to do from with
you if you got any other ones that you
would add to list comment on the bottom
if you got any questions or thoughts
also comment on the bottom or you give
us our pillow here that made it oh
that's a nice throw what a distance
throw right you are like two feet away
from me okay
hey if you haven't subscribed subscribe
to this channel on the bottom here our
goal is to get to 1 million subs by the
end of 2017 to get to 1 million subs
with value teaming by the end of 2017
because we believe pound for pound there
are a lot of motivational YouTube
channels out there there are a lot of
channels that we keep regurgitating the
same exact thing with another different
place and another different vlog in
another different platform here you come
to value to me for one reason we're
going to show you how to do things on
this channel how to how to become more
creative how to hire how to fire how to
put business plans together how to
become a better culture in your office
everything's on how for you to make your
business better for free so you need to
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet because we need you we need you to
help us get 2 million subs we need you
to help us get 2 million subs we just
recently cross over 150,000 subs we got
850 more to go by the end of 2017 to get
2 million subs and by the way some of
you guys would say that's crazy
for a child like we believe it's
possible we think we can get 2 million
subs to you if you do help us get there
thanks so much for watching everybody
take care bye bye
you
[Music]